les les jeunes les enfants qui sont à
l'école il n'y a pas de distribution
discrimination sociale ils ont tous les
gens qui ont moins d'argent la même
enceinte il y a pas le mec elle est Nike
ou le le sac il sent Laurent et en plus
il y a une certaine discipline et moi je
suis une femme très à cheval sur les
principes je trouve que l'uniforme
devrait être quasiment
obligatoire en tout cas en France et je
trouve ça très bien comme à l'époque de
nos grands-mères et nos grands-pères et
je trouve que Notre Dame de France est
très élégante et j'aime beaucoup sa
coiffure darling I Love You merci
les séries est-ce que il y en a qui sont
pour l'uniforme ici
c'est tout à fait ça ça gomme un peu
toutes les inégalités sociales que tu as
tout le monde a même enseigne c'est pas
grave mais si tu te salir en chimie ou
en autre voilà non ça très bien très
bien Afida avec tout mon respect
n'importe quoi
c'est le sexisme et la discrimination
elle est pas pure mais dans nos
territoires
[Musique]
tu dis n'importe quoi dans nos
territoires d'outre-mer par exemple il y
a le port de l'uniforme à l'école qui
passe très très bien et on n'est pas et
on n'est pas du tout obligé de d'obliger
les gens
ils peuvent très bien avoir un pantalon
et c'est toi
en fait imagine le problème
c'est que oui tu es mon pote je te dis
la vérité c'est que tu es encore dans un
truc je sais pas au courant de tout ce
qui se passe et le problème c'est que tu
es pas au courant que le pantalon était
autorisé donc en fait ton histoire de
sexisme en fait n'existe pas donc quel
est ton autre argument l'argument c'est
que aujourd'hui pour s'individualiser et
non plus être des robots les jeunes
c'est par l'habit que ça passe c'est par
les vêtements c'est pas porter des
tenues qu'on aime qui reflète l'âme et
vous voulez les standards
parce que vous êtes le prototype de la
femme robotisée
que tous les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
doivent leur non mais regardez-vous
c'est pas ça la France c'est pas ça
je préfère que ma jeunesse que la
jeunesse justement s'individualise et
soit et se sortent du lot non pas par
leur fringues mais parce qu'ils vont
être par leur être
vous vous seriez pas beaucoup sortis
et la vie ne fait pas le moine non c'est
pour ça que tu gueules toi bah oui parce
qu'on entend pour dire une banalité
c'est la réalité
il y a du monde des deux côtés c'est à
dire qu'à la fois c'est vrai que c'est
bien au niveau qui est pas trop de
différence sociale ça c'est super mais à
la fois je trouve ça bien aussi que
chacun puisse sentir libre de mettre ce
qu'il a envie ici c'est pas moi l'odeur
on parle dans les écoles ou même au
collège après
comme il veut
pas comme ça il y aurait peut-être plus
de bière aussi
[Applaudissements]
non mais Gilles pardon mais tu dis
n'importe quoi ma couille c'est pas
parce qu'on roule c'est pas parce qu'on
revient à quelque chose qu'on faisait
avant que c'est nécessairement
rétrograde effectivement ça règle les
problèmes de discrimination et puis un
autre point qu'elle a souligné c'est que
ça règle aussi les problèmes budgétaires
c'est très cher d'habiller les enfants
d'avoir toujours les dernières balances
là ça coûte beaucoup moins cher donc ça
règle énormément de problèmes et c'est
pas rétrograde c'est adapté à notre
société au contraire et ça facilite le
quotidien des maires beaucoup de
souffrance c'est vrai j'ai vu qu'il y
avait j'ai vu qu'il y avait quelqu'un
qui avait critiqué l'ex dealer
nouvellement député Louis Boyard ce
qu'il avait des chaussures très chères à
la gare
franchement je le défends ce qu'il veut
s'il a envie de s'acheter des chaussures
non mais c'est toi qui les critiqué
quand il est mal habillé et puis du coup
il a critiqué
sont tous bleus
on s'en fout qu'il ait des choses sur
neuves
6000 balles par mois net encore heureux
qui s'achètent des chaussures propres
c'est le tweet qui fait que ces
chaussures dégueulasse qui est une
insulte envers les gens je vais aller
manifester avec des chaussettes craquées
et des chaussures craquées et déchirées
pourquoi faire même les gens qui ont pas
d'argent ils sont plus digne que toi ils
ont des cheveux manifesté
au sol là pour aller à la manifeste et
s'il va chez des magasins comme des
capons c'est 15 balles des chaussures
Naves à chaque fois des chaussures neuf
arrête de snober les gens comme ça c'est
dégueulasse en fait
[Musique]
ce dealer nouvellement député absolument
d'accord
il fait pas de la politique il fait du
putaclic en fait quand il vient sur un
plateau télé c'est pour qu'on parle de
lui quand il fait un tweet c'est pour
qu'on parle de lui ce qui l'intéresse
c'est d'avoir trois articles sur melty
buzz et pas faire avancer